[موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى] لقد
قمت بتصوير نفس مجموعة
خروف البحر قبل ثلاث سنوات، ولكن
أصبح من الواضح من خلال فقدان الموائل
أن أعداد خروف البحر آخذة في
الانخفاض، لذلك أردنا العودة إلى
كريستال ريفر لفهم ماهية تلك
الظروف  والمساعدة في تثقيف
جمهورنا حول ما يحدث مع
فلوريدا خروف البحر، كنت أشعر بالفضول لمعرفة ما إذا
كانوا لا يزالون هناك حتى لو تمكنا من
السباحة معهم كما فعلنا في
السنوات السابقة
لحسن الحظ بالنسبة لنا، فقد كانوا هناك
ونزلنا إلى الماء و  لقد تمكنا
بالفعل من الدخول إلى ربيع الأخوات الثلاثة المشهور
عالميًا، وهو
مجمع مشهور عالميًا لخراف البحر وهو
مفتوح فقط لأيام معينة للزوار، لذلك كنا
محظوظين جدًا لأنه في اليوم الذي ذهبنا فيه
للتصوير معهم كان الربيع مفتوحًا
وهناك  كان هناك الكثير من خراف البحر
هناك مخاطرة بالسباحة مع خراف
البحر نعم نحن نتحدث عن ثدييات بحرية كبيرة جدًا، هناك عمالقة لطيفون
دون أدنى شك أنهم من
ألطف المخلوقات التي يمكن أن
تصادفها في المحيط ومع ذلك،  لا تزال
كبيرة الحجم، وإذا لم تتبع
القواعد وكيفية الاقتراب منها والسباحة
معهم، فقد يكون ذلك خطيرًا، كما أنك
تتطلع أيضًا إلى سلامتهم أيضًا،
ومن الأشياء التي لا تريد
رؤيتها أبدًا هو تعرض خروف البحر للمضايقة  أو أن
يكون خروف البحر محصورًا في منطقة ما
لأن السباحين يحاولون الحصول على
اللقطة السحرية الصحيحة أو
الصورة المثالية، فمعرفة متى تثبت على الأرض
ومعرفة متى تتراجع هو أمر
مهم جدًا عند التصوير مع
خروف البحر وليس فقط من أجل  من
أجلهم ولكن أيضًا من أجلك أيضًا،
أعتقد أن المشاهدين يستجيبون لتلك
التجربة الغامرة التي
مررت بها مع خروف البحر وكان من الممكن أن تكون
أي شخص، وهذا هو هدفنا الرئيسي من خلال
المحتوى ومقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بنا التي نحاول جذب
الجمهور إليها.
المغامر في هذه الحالة كان أنا
وفريقي، لذا فقد حصلوا على لمحة عما
قد يكون عليه الحال عندما تكون في الماء
مع مخلوق مهيب مثل
خروف البحر الأجنبي في فلوريدا
[موسيقى]